bonjour à tous aujourd'hui est un grand
jour voilà ma nouvelle caméra pour
l'instant je suis encore en train de
filmer sur mon dos -maux plus mais à
partir de demain après-demain retrait
très rapidement on va tous filmés avec
le panasonic gh1 5 un modèle juste
génial qui arrive juste après le hashtag
de chez panasonic sais pas si vous
connaissiez c'était déjà un produit qui
était sublime
en terme de qualité vidéo en termes de
qualité photo mais là on va encore plus
loin alors dans cette vidéo je vais pas
vous faire une présentation complète de
cet appareil ce plan parce que je ne
maîtrise pas encore il va falloir un
certain temps pour bien naviguer dans
les menus pour apprendre vraiment à le
connaître et à comprendre complètement
comment ils fonctionnent et puis
l'optimiser mais on va faire un tour on
va faire un boxing on va regarder ce qui
est dans la boîte suis très content
parce qu'en pouvoir faire plein de
nouvelles choses avec
il offre de nouvelles possibilités on va
encore repoussé les frontières et on va
s'éclater
aujourd'hui c'est presque mieux que noël
la dinde en moi voilà la bête avant
toute chose je tiens à dire que cette
vidéo n'est pas du tout sponsorisé c'est
mon matériel mon matériel pour tourner
pour filmer je les ai achetés avec mes
petits sous panasonic ne m'a pas payé
par son nom mattéï est rassuré alors
j'ai acheté le décès gh5 elle bon connu
sous le nom de gh5 le lumix panasonic
c'est vraiment un appareil qui est une
vraie bombe atomique parce que on peut
filmer alors en 4k ça vous me direz on
peut le faire aujourd'hui un peu partout
sauf chez cannon chez canon toujours la
capitale annonce la passe sous le nez
c'est pas possible
celui ci en plus il a la particularité
d'avoir une stabilisation sur cinq axes
on a un mode que gestion plus c'est le
petit pour avoir le mode vailog pour
pouvoir avoir une image
plate pour pouvoir vraiment travailler
sur de la colorimétrie donc s'en va le
regarder je vais vous on va regarder au
ska dedans et puis rajouter bien sûr une
petite batterie passe quand on part au
footing c'est quand même dommage se
retrouve à court de batterie
alors première chose on va ouvrir cette
jolie boîte et puis on va regarder un
peu ce qu'il a dans le ventre
après on y va bonjour alors qu'est-ce
qu'a dans cette boîte bien évidemment
des manuels d'utilisation
ça me paraît quand même être aujourd'hui
que ce important
bonjour alors je les prie le modèle mois
avec l'objectif c'est le 12 60 laika
avec l'ouverture de 8,4 je les tester
c'est vrai que la lumière aléas les tops
se produit il est vraiment magnifique
alors c'est le produit qui est vendu
d'origine avec mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu un produit de ce que j'en ai vu
de ce que j'ai pu lire les différentes
vidéos
c'est un produit qu'un peu passe partout
qui permet d'avoir un excellent rendu
dès le départ sans forcément chercher
des objectifs qui vont forcément être
beaucoup plus cher celui là déjà il est
super ça il faut savoir que nu ça ça
coûte déjà à peu près 9 cents et
quelques robes on sait pas c'est pas
cadeau cadeaux alors tac tac tac tac
bon ben ça c'est pour votre objectif
voyons voir la bête
bon la lanière gh5 ou maintenant le
joujou au lui-même bon dans la boîte
mais quoi pour les gens regardent
comment les accessoires on va l'ouvrir
après celle là là c'est pour la recharge
on doit avoir le câble de recharge qui
est ici on a bien évidemment une
batterie et là on a on a on a des
accessoires en ce sens je ne sais pas on
verra plus tard ce que c'est alors on va
sortir ce boîtier sur ces l'instant
émotions voilà gh5 panasonic c'est
presque une petite larme à l'oeil alors
c'est vrai ce que je le savais que ce
boîtier on ne se connaît pas encore
c'est un peu comme une rencontre
amoureuse
je sais qu'on va vivre de folles
aventures on part d'ici quelques jours
aux états unis on va d'abord faire un
petit stop à new york où je vais vous
faire différentes vidéos là bas on part
ensuite au csa vegas cet appareil a
vraiment offrir de la flexibilité va
vraiment me permettre de faire des
choses
assez plus travailler plus facilement
plus professionnellement
voilà donc c'est vraiment ce que je
recherchais j'aime vraiment d'un besoin
d'un produit dans cet esprit là est pour
moi le panasonic le jeu h5
c'est vraiment vraiment de la bombe
atomique alors l'écran bien évidemment
est complètement tactile et pivote je
pose mon objectif déçu mais pas à dire
il est super élégant pas ce que vous en
pensez mais je trouve moi qu'il a
vraiment de la gueule on peut regarder
sous tous les angles
c'est un produit qui est vraiment
magnifique on va jeter un petit coup
d'oeil on va ouvrir la batterie puis on
va regarder vite fait le menu
non merci la batterie se trouve ici vous
avez si vous des lecteurs pour mettre
votre carte mémoire attention par contre
faut vraiment faire super attention
lorsque vous mettez vos cartes sd de
choisir les bonnes cartes sd pour
pouvoir vraiment ce que si vous filmez
en cas de kharg voulait prendre de la
gare de la photo et la 4k dans la
meilleure définition il faut avoir des
cartes en lecture et en écriture qui
soit vraiment très rapide il vous faut
des cartes qui coûte à peu près de
l'ordre de 150 160 euros si t'es pas de
bêtises donc bon c'est un investissement
mais si on veut vraiment la meilleure
qualité c'est ce que je vous invite à
faire il n'y a pas lésiné dessus allez
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
l'allumer
on a les différents menus formats photos
format vidéo
justement vos skis matin sur un pic à
traiter d'enregistrement fjd en 50
images secondes le voyons avec 4 cale en
effet hd 50i matsui choix pour le moment
les réglages le menu est hyper complexe
et donc on va pas regarder la suite à
leur stabilisation moi ça ça m'intéresse
relâchement le mode stabilisation
stabilisation tac
oui après bon vous avez effectivement un
plein de choses un mode d'enregistrement
pour la vidéo c'est vraiment très très
complets tout ça je le regarde un peu
plus tard plus en détails que je vous
ferai un petit compte-rendu parce que
bien évidemment
il ya énormément de choses à se dire sur
ce sur ce boîtier est là tout sur une
vidéo de prise en main donc on va rester
un petit peu sobre
maintenant on va acheter un petit coup
d'oeil au reste alors bon ici c'est la
deuxième batterie dont il n'a pas grand
chose à dire dessus d'un effectivement
vous avez hop une deuxième batterie et
puis vous avez ici alors ça pour moi
salle indispensable quand on veut faire
de la vidéo sur sur ce produit là c'est
la clef de mise à niveau logicielle pour
avoir le mode vailog et pour pouvoir
débloquer votre appareil parce qu'il
faut savoir que d'origine vous pouvez
filmer uniquement une demi heure et
après sa coupe alors vous me direz déjà
filmé une demi-heure en statique ne vont
pas trop forcément ce que vous allez en
faire qu il faut pas que ça abîme après
votre capteur mais surtout le mode très
intéressant avec ça c'est d'avoir le
mode vailog qui est complètement
déverrouiller alors on va acheté un
petit coup d'oeil à l'intérieur de la
boîte
alors hop manuel d'installation
c'est bien faire et c'est ça avec le
sceau de monde si ça a été déjà ouverts
ou pas alors là au dos il ya mon code
bien évidemment je vous le montre pas
sinon ce serait franchement idiot donc
voilà un peu tout de suite pour la prise
en main de ce panasonic gh1 5
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire alors
bon après je vous dis on trouvera dans
les tailles un peu plus tard mais c'est
vrai que c'est un produit moi je suis je
suis je suis super fan je suis très très
amoureux et je pense qu'avec ça on va
vraiment bien s'amuser voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire sur ce nouveau boîtier le
panasonic lumix g à 5 ans betty dont on
va beaucoup parler puis surtout sûr
qu'elle va voir beaucoup d'image puisque
c'est maintenant mon boîtier principal
donc je vais filmer avec ce dernier
toujours à la main alors nous voir oui
et non sur les images que vous allez
voir
mais voilà un peu pour ce tout nouveau
produit alors je vous invite à laisser
des commentaires et ce que vous le
connaissez vous l'avez déjà testé est-ce
que vous avez déjà testé le ghk
peut-être d'autres produits chez
panasonic est ce que vous utilisez si
vous êtes vous youtuber au cratère
contenu est
déjà différentes boîtes extrait du
canyon sony panasonic nikon ou autre
marc et moi tout ça en commentaires
dites moi quel est qu'est-ce que vous
recommande rigueur pour avoir vraiment
un produit un peu passe-partout compact
et puis surtout avec des fonctionnalités
de des logs et la stabilisation
cinq axes vous mettez tout ça je vous
invite à mener c'est des jolies pousse à
vous abonner
parce que on va changer pas mal de
choses on va améliorer pas mal de choses
et on va aller encore plus loin
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
vous embrasse soyez sage je vous dis à
très bientôt ciao